if you want to build a really big
building you dig the foundation
differently it goes deeper and it goes
wider which means that for a period of
time anyone who looks at you you're
below the ground and you're doing stuff
that has no progress the thing is is
that the longer you build in this
foundational period the higher you will
ultimately be able to build the building
that is the success the achievement but
the problem is is that the fastest way
to get to a million is not the fastest
way to get to 10 million the fastest way
to get to 10 million is not the fastest
way to get to 100 million and so the way
that you play the game how tall you want
the building to be ultimately has to get
reversed into the present which is why
it's so important to think big and also
cut out anything that isn't aligned with
that big goal of yours because it will
change how you play